eine ruinenstadt verband und zerschossen
in spanischen bürgerkrieg
als wäre sie zu bernsteiner statt
rätselhafte geisterschiff dem verfall
preisgegeben
[Musik]
die sind richtig unheimlich
eine brücke ins nirgendwo versteckt in
einem deutschen wald
wie aus einer anderen welt man fragt
sich was sie da solche
und mysteriöse metallteile entdeckt im
amerikanischen nordostens jetzt
praktisch am ende der welt
[Applaus]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
diese bauten aufgegeben manche sind
heute lebensgefährlich verseucht wer hat
sie errichtet und wie und warum wurden
sie ausgemustert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im nordosten spaniens 50 kilometer von
saragossa entfernt liegt eine
geisterstadt
[Musik]
ein ort der zerstörung nur ruinen und
menschenleere straßen und doch von
eigenartiger schönheit
[Musik]
der gut hin hört hört angeblich noch die
stimmen aus der vergangenheit
deren ihnen erzählen davon dass hier
etwas schlimmes passiert ist
war es ein erdbeben eine überstürzte
evakuierung wer hat diese häuser
zerstört und warum wurden sie wieder
aufgebaut
die verlassene stadt heißt bild schickte
gleich daneben liegt seltsamerweise eine
weitere kleinstadt mit demselben namen
was steckt hinter dieser rätselhaften
dopplung und warum ist einer der beiden
orte total zerstört
auf den zweiten blick wird deutlich dass
nicht wind und wetter dieser häuser auf
dem gewissen haben sondern kugeln und
granaten
überall sind einschusslöcher
das ist keine normale erosion sondern
die handschrift des krieges
wer hat bitte angegriffen und warum
wurde es nie wieder aufgebaut
ein blick zurück in spanien tobt
zwischen 1936 und 1939 ein blutiger
bürgerkrieg
im kampf um die zweite spanische
republik der konflikt bricht aus als die
nationalistische militärführung gegen
die demokratisch gewählte volksfront
pusht
diese ist ein bündnis linker kräfte
anführer danach journalisten ist der
faschistische general francisco franco
der spanien bis zu seinem tod im jahr
1975 mit eiserner hand regieren wird
franco bekommt während des bürgerkriegs
unterstützung aus mussolinis italien
und hitlers nazi deutschland
die republikaner werden von der
sowjetunion unterstützt und von
internationalen brigaden darunter
kommunisten marxisten und antifaschisten
auch viele frauen kämpfen während des
spanischen bürgerkriegs auf ihrer seite
der spanische bürgerkrieg begann als
nationale angelegenheit auf der einen
seite stand die linksgerichtete
regierung auf der anderen die
rechtsgerichteten militärs die gegen die
gewählte regierung geputscht haben
ein jahr später kontrollierten francos
truppen großer teile spaniens
aber die republikaner leisten
erbitterten widerstand
im august 1937 starten sie einen angriff
auf saragossa
die hauptstadt aragoniens ist ein
wichtiges kommunikations zentrum der
nationalisten
in strategischer hinsicht war saragossa
nicht besonders bedeutend aber es wäre
ein sieg für die republikanische moral
gewesen
auf dem weg nach saragossa liegt bild.de
[Musik]
ursprünglich wollten die republikaner
einen bogen darum machen
aber dann greifen sie doch an
[Musik]
die nationalisten hatten in bälde ein
paar tausend soldaten stationiert
keine elite truppe aber doch gut genug
ausgestattet um den autor festung zu
machen die republikaner hätten saragossa
einnehmen können stattdessen
verzettelten sie sich in ein scharmützel
um eine kleinstadt mit 3800 einwohnern
wer kämpft in der schlacht
umweltschützer auf seiten der
republikaner
sind es nationale oder internationale
streitkräfte
die umsturzpläne von franco und seinen
faschistischen mitstreitern hatten
weltweit für proteste gesorgt die
gewählte regierung erfuhr dagegen große
solidarität besonders aus den westlichen
ländern kamen viele freiwillige die sie
aktiv unterstützen wollten
rund 3000 freiwillige stammen aus den
vereinigten staaten sie gründen das
lincoln bataillon und kämpfen an der
seite der republikaner
[Musik]
bis zum einsatz in bild schielte hatte
sich das linke nation zu einer
erstklassigen truppe gemausert die
männer hatten kampf erfahrung gesammelt
und waren inzwischen richtig gute
soldaten
was anfangs nicht unbedingt der fall
gewesen
beim angriff auf bild.de kennen die
amerikaner kein pardon
fremdenführer galindo simon beschreibt
die ersten stunden des zermürbenden
häuserkampfes
sie beschossen den ort mit artillerie
und granatwerfern
[Musik]
26 panzer bahn auch im einsatz sie
griffen von allen seiten
die zivilisten haben keine möglichkeit
zur flucht sie verschanzen sich in ihren
kellern während über ihnen die schlacht
tobt
belagerungszustand
die leute waren von der versorgung
abgeschnitten von außen kamen wieder
wasser noch lebensmittel das alles war
sehr brutal denn die angreifer nahmen
auf die zivilisten keine rücksicht
francos truppen haben einen
strategischen vorteil von der spitze des
heute arg lädierten kirchturms haben sie
freie schussbahn auf die stellungen der
republikaner
[Musik]
für die republikaner war es sehr wichtig
die kirche einzel nehmen denn im team
von wo aus die sicht sehr gut war
standen maschinengewehre
[Musik]
hier können wir eine granate sehen die
immer noch im gemäuer steckt
[Musik]
die republikanischen truppen können erst
dann in den ort vordringen wenn sie die
maschinengewehr schützen ausgeschaltet
haben
da drüben ist die stelle wo das linken
bataillon der republikaner
durchgebrochen ist
die straßen von bild schielte sind sehr
eng und verwinkelt wie
der panzer noch andere fahrzeuge kam
hierdurch auch weil überall trümmer
lagen
die kämpfer mussten bildtitel haus für
haus einnehmen
das sind die härtesten geschichte
überhaupt es geht mann gegen mann der
tag die explosionen du arbeitest dich
von einem haus zum nächsten vor wirst
handgranaten reist wende einbrechers den
feind aus das bedeutet hohe verluste auf
beiden seiten
nach zwei wochen erbitterten kampfes
haben die republikaner und ihre
amerikanischen verbündeten die stadt
schließlich unter kontrolle
[Musik]
es war eine blutige angelegenheit
und besonders schlimm für die
einheimischen
ernest hemingway berichtete damals für
amerikanische zeitungen über den krieg
als er in bälde ankam sagte er der ort
sei weniger eine stadt als ein übler
geruch gewesen
bei glühender hitze verwesen in den
straßen die opfer des kampfes
insgesamt an die 3000 menschen
die männer vom linken bataillon sprachen
später von einem der härtesten einsätze
des ganzen krieges
sie wussten nicht wieso sie als elite
brigade in einen häuserkampf verwickelt
worden waren
im rückblick war das ein schwerer fehler
dass bisschen raumgewinn hatte überhaupt
keinen strategischen nutzen gebracht
nach nur sechs monaten erobern die
truppen der nationalisten welche zurück
aber warum wollte die stadt nie wieder
aufgebaut
franco wollte es nicht er nutzte die
anfängliche niederlage der nationalisten
in bälde zu propagandazwecken man könnte
meinen dass siege dafür besser geeignet
wären aber nicht für einen diktator er
verwies auf dieses schreckliche desaster
bei dem zahlreiche zivilisten ums leben
gekommen waren und sagte ohne mich wird
so etwas wieder passieren
franco verbot den wiederaufbau darum
beschlossen die einheimischen gleich
daneben eine neue stadt zu bauen
[Musik]
heute ist die ruinenstadt vor allem ein
denkmal für die tausenden die hier ihr
leben verloren haben
und ein mahnmal das an die brutalität
des spanischen bürgerkriegs erinnert
wie ein zu bernstein erstarrtes
kriegsgebiet die spuren sind überall zu
sehen die einschusslöcher die granaten
treffer die tragödie des krieges besteht
häufig doch auch darin dass nicht nur
verfeindeten armeen gegeneinander
kämpfen sondern dass auch zivilisten in
die schusslinie geraten genau das ist
hier geschehen und das macht die sache
so herzzerreißend
[Musik]
an der kanadischen westküste knapp 200
kilometer von vancouver entfernt
befindet sich das städtchen powell river
[Musik]
fest miteinander verteilt liegen hier
rätselhafte boote in einer langen reihe
vor anker
[Musik]
es sieht aus wie eine geisterstadt deren
besatzung auf mysteriöse weise
verschwunden ist es ganz schön
unheimlich welche werte
sie sind mit muscheln moos und seetang
überwuchert als würde die natur sie
zurückfordern
schwere rostige captain halten die
schiffe an ihrem platz die besatzung ist
schon lange verschwunden
was verbirgt sich unter deck manche
leute glauben dass da immer noch schätze
an bord sind wenn sie nur irgendwie rein
kämen würden sie schon was finden
die mit moos bewachsenen kenne geben
ihre geheimnisse auf den ersten blick
nicht preis eines aber haben alle
gemeinsam
[Musik]
das wirklich ungewöhnliche an ihnen ist
dass sie nicht aus stahl gemacht sind
sondern aus beton die sonst nie konkret
weil man hier aufwächst fragt man sich
was sind das für schiffe wie sind sie
hierher gekommen
was haben sie für eine geschichte
und gibt es womöglich einen zusammenhang
zu einer der tödlichsten waffen aller
zeiten
[Musik]
1917 seit drei jahren tobt in europa der
erste weltkrieg
an vielen stellen der front hat der
blutige stellungskrieg zu einer art patt
situation geführt die verluste gehen auf
beiden seiten in die millionen
auch die britisch-französische
großoffensive an das sonnen im vorjahr
ist nach über vier monaten wirkungslos
verpufft
im april 1917 treten die usa in den
krieg ein und schließen sich den
alliierten an in den nächsten 15 monaten
werden sie über eine million soldaten
nach frankreich schicken die meisten
davon sind bodentruppen
auch eine schlagkräftige flotte wird
gebraucht
allerdings ist stahl das klassische
rohmaterial für den schiffbau knapp eine
andere lösung muss her
[Musik]
irgendjemand kam auf die idee beton zu
verwenden
gewöhnliche beton ist zu schwer aber sie
entwickelten eine neue art die zugleich
leicht und robust war
während des ersten weltkriegs war beton
eine echte alternative
stahl wurde für die waffenproduktion
gebraucht beton dagegen war
kostengünstig und funktionell und konnte
auch schwimmen
die us-regierung ist so beeindruckt von
den schiffen dass sie gleich 24 stück
bestellt
als sie fertig waren war der krieg schon
vorbei
trotzdem kamen sie zum einsatz und
funktionierten sehr gut
so ein beton schiff ist ziemlich
langlebig
beton verschleißt viel langsamer als
stahl und rostet nicht
er ist praktisch unverwüstlich
so unverwüstlich dass die konstrukteure
bei der nächsten stahl knappheit während
des zweiten weltkriegs erneut auf das
baumaterial zurückgreifen
die meisten beton schiffe kamen als
frachter zum einsatz güter lassen sich
darin sehr gut lagern
die leute in paul river nennen die
branche für vor ihrem hafen hals kolosse
wie aber kann die zehn ausgedehnten
weltkriegs frachter nach kanada
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
entstehen an der pazifik-küste
zahlreiche papiermühlen so auch hier in
paul das
holz für die papierproduktion kam auf
dem wasserweg an und landete in
sogenannten holz teilchen um die
sicherheit der arbeiter zu gewährleisten
mussten diese teiche so gut wie möglich
geschützt werden vor dem starken wind
von süden und von norden und von der
strömung
die besitzer der papiermühle beschließen
einen wellenbrecher zu errichten damit
die holzstämme nicht mehr im offenen
meer treiben
maschinenbauingenieur
modernisten erklärt das prinzip
holen oder wellenbrecher bestehen
normalerweise aus großen fels haufen die
auf dem meeresboden aufgeschüttet werden
in unserem fall ist das nicht möglich
das meer ist einfach zu tief so entstand
die idee schiffe zu verwenden
[Musik]
stahl ist in salzwasser nicht besonders
langlebig schiff aus stahl würden sich
vielleicht 20 jahre halten die meisten
unserer branche für waren dagegen schon
jahrzehnte alt als sie hierher kamen um
die älteren zu ersetzen und sie halten
jetzt bereits seit über 50 jahren
1948 treffen die ersten beton schiffe in
powell river ein
niemand weiß ob sie tatsächlich als
wellenbrecher taugen
die schiffe wurden verankert und
zusammengekettet so bildeten sie eine
art künstlichen damm
um den elementen standhalten zu können
wurden sie mit kies beschwert und in
richtung küste geneigt
sie sind bedeutend schwerer als normale
schiffe und können die wellen deshalb
viel besser brechen
minister schiffe hat eine besondere
geschichte die uss cole baujahr 1943
sie war eines der ziele schiffe bei den
atomtests die das us militär auf dem
bikini atoll durchführte und zwar bei
dem test namens becker
dabei wird im juli 1946 eine atombombe
unterwasser gezündet
die explosion schleuderte eine fast zwei
kilometer hohe wassersäule in die luft
die radioaktive wolke kontaminiert
zahlreiche schiffe darunter auch die uss
kurz
sie wollten wissen welchen effekt
atombomben auf schiffe haben deshalb
positionierte das militär dort schiffe
aller art später wurde dann auch
untersucht wie stark sich die
radioaktivität bei welcher entfernung
auswirkt
zehn jahre später und angeblich
dekontaminiert landet die uss quarz im
power über
ihre lebensdauer wurde einst auf 15
jahre geschätzt inzwischen sind über 75
jahre vergangen und sie hält immer noch
vier der zehn betonwerks sollen versenkt
werden der anfang ist bereits gemacht
[Musik]
der grund die papiermühle braucht keine
großen holz teilchen jahr
geplant ist einige der beton schiffe zu
versenken und zu künstlichen riffen zu
machen an denen sich pflanzen und tiere
ansiedeln können
die schiffe sind außergewöhnliche
beispiele für eine gelungene technologie
sie wurden aus der not geboren als neue
materialien für den schiffsbau dringend
gebraucht wurden
das vorbei war fanden sie eine neue
verwendung als wellenbrecher nun da auch
hier der bedarf geringer ist können sie
am meeresgrund noch nützlich sein die
boote sind der beweis dafür wie
vielseitig materialien verwendet werden
können wenn man ein bisschen fantasie
hat
[Musik]
in einem wald in oberbayern stoßen wir
auf beton ruinen ganz anderer art
[Musik]
sie sind teil einer kargen felsen
landschaft
[Musik]
er ist eine negative energie so als ob
wir etwas schlimmes passiert wäre
alles wird ganz natürlich doch aus den
felsen wachsen mittag stangen
so spaziert nichts ahnend durch den wald
und plötzlich läuft auf beton ein
fußabdruck taucht auf und dann nach
einer
du fragst dich was ist hier geschehen
von wem stammen die abdrücke und was
wurde aus den menschen
je weiter man kommt desto rätselhafter
wirtes rostiger stahl und verwitterte
beton nehmen immer seltsamere formen an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was immer da gewütet hat es hatte
wahnsinnige kraft roses mal spanisch und
es geht noch weiter unter dem waldboden
liegt ein rätselhafte tunnel
zwischen den bäumen lauern seltsame
vertiefungen
besonders unheimlich ist dieser
betonboden eine brücke nach nirgendwo
wie hängt das alles zusammen
[Musik]
es sieht aus wie eine gigantische
dinosaurier rippe die aus der erde ragt
das ganze hat etwas fantastisches wie
aus einer anderen welt man fragt sich
wer errichtete diesen bogen was wurde
aus den menschen die ihnen gebaut haben
und was führte zu seiner zerstörung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gegen ende des zweiten weltkriegs
erreichen die luftangriffe der
alliierten ihren höhepunkt
[Musik]
nach der landung der alliierten verloren
die deutschen erst die luft herrschaft
über frankreich und dann die über ihrem
eigenen land
die alliierten wollen mit einem
bombenkrieg gegen deutsche städte und
gemeinden die moral der deutschen
bevölkerung brechen doch ihre strategie
geht nicht ganz auf
[Musik]
auch die industrielle produktion geht
vorerst weiter aber je länger der krieg
dauert desto effektiver werden die
schläge der alliierten gegen industrie
und infrastruktur
[Musik]
alliierte bomber zerstörung eine fabrik
nach der anderen das deutsche reich
gerät immer mehr unter druck
die deutschen brauchten eine neue
verteidigungsstrategie
der sogenannte jäger starb wird
begründet um die herstellung von
jagdflugzeugen zu steigern dafür sollen
teile der produktion in bunker verlegt
werden
bunker lassen sich allerdings nicht so
leicht in velsen bauen
so kamen die deutschen auf die idee
künstliche hüllen anzulegen
die anlage bekommt den namen weingut 1
der halb unterirdische riesige rüstungs
bunker ist teil eines konzepts das die
deutsche kriegsmaschinerie in gang
halten soll
aber warum liegt er ausgerechnet hier an
diesem abgelegenen fleck in oberbayern
[Musik]
der historiker er hat bosch erklärt
welche voraussetzungen der standort
erfüllen musste
[Musik]
es war also dringend nötig um python
bauten zu machen brauche ich kießig
brauchwasser ich brauche zement und
stahl und das war hier vorhanden
der bau der anlage ist ein wahres
mammutprojekt
[Musik]
der bunker sollte aus zwölf gewölbe
bögen bestehen auf einer länge von 400
metern
pro bogen also über 30 meter
ein riesiges bauprojekt
ab juli 1944 schuften über 10.000 mann
für die bunkeranlage weingut 1 der
großteil davon zwangsarbeiter
solche böden sind eine architektonische
herausforderung wenn sie erst einmal
stehen sind sie stabil vorne aber
während der bauarbeiten müssen sie
sorgfältig abgestützt werden
holz und stahl sind knapp und fallen als
stützen für die schalung aus
deshalb greifen die architekten auf ein
anderes material zurück hiess
sie brauchten so viel kies wie sie nur
kriegen konnten denn das anvisierte
bauverfahren verschlang berge von
kieselsteinen
die berge von kies dienten quasi als
schalung scan für das zu errichtende
beton gewölbe
wie aber sollten die kiesmenge nach der
fertigstellung eines bogens zum bau des
nächsten bewegt werden ein hinweis
findet sich in einiger entfernung
dies ist ein unterirdischer transport
tunnel sobald ein bogen fertig war wurde
der kies durch bodenluke nin güter loren
gefüllt die brachten ihn dann zur
nächsten baustelle
in den bunkern sollen flugzeuge gebaut
werden insbesondere die messerschmitt me
das erste in serie hergestellte
jagdflugzeug mit strahltriebwerken
[Musik]
das halbrunde bunker dach unter dem die
pflege entstehen sollen ist praktisch
bombensicher wir sind hier und am
siebten bogen die fundamente rechts und
links den 17 meter tief runter und in
der marke betont sie sehen sie hier oben
teilweise ist die abgebrochen da hat man
schon die ersten armierungseisen und in
diese ist man dann fünf meter mehr
eingebaut
nach der fertigstellung sollte hier in
großem stil produziert werden
sie wollten hier dann runter graben
hätten dann acht stockwerke
fabrikationshallen jahr das vierte
stockwerk war zur be- und entlüftung
geplant und wenn man das betrachtet die
gesamte fläche die man gehabt ihre
produktionsfläche waren 114 1000
quadratmeter fläche das entspricht etwa
14 fußballfelder
welche verbindung besteht zwischen den
riesigen gewölbe bögen und den tiefen
krater die in drei kilometer entfernung
den bogen zu erforschen
diese krater finden sich in der ganzen
umgebung von außen lässt sich kaum sagen
wie sie entstanden sind aber sie sind
wirklich riesig
die krater sind anteil der finsteren
geschichte von weingut 1 das
größtenteils von kz häftlingen und
sowjetischen kriegsgefangenen gebaut
wurde
[Musik]
da wo sich heute die erde wirkt waren
damals ihre behausung sie litten unter
katastrophalen bedingungen
[Musik]
sie hatten keine heizungen keine
toiletten keine waschbecken es gab nicht
mal wasser
sie hatten eine unzureichende
verpflegung es können sie sich
vorstellen dass sie also sehr schnell
abgemagert amt
wenn sie geflohen worden sex sind sind
sie erschossen erwischt worden sind
tausende zwangsarbeiter kommen beim bau
von weingut eines ums leben
sieben gewölbe bögen werden bis april
1945 fertiggestellt ein paar tage später
ist der krieg zu ende
im mai übernehmen die amerikaner die
kontrolle über das areal sie haben
großes strategisches interesse an der
monumentalen bunkeranlage
[Musik]
im hinblick auf einen möglichen dritten
weltkrieg spielten die amerikaner mit
dem gedanken solche bunker auch in den
usa zu bauen zuerst wollten sie aber das
material testen also beschlossen sie es
in die luft zu jagen
sechs der sieben bögen werden auf diese
weise zerstört danach ist klar wie viel
sprengstoff gebraucht wird um die bunker
zu vernichten
die bauart vieler nuklear bunker aus der
zeit des kalten krieges geht auf die
erkenntnisse zurück die hier 1947 bei
den spring tests in weingut 1 gewonnen
wurden
am ende bleiben die ruinen verlassen
zurück
[Musik]
wenn man sich weingut 1 ansieht wo die
nazis zwangsarbeiter auf brutalste weise
ausbeuteten um ihre kriegsmaschinerie am
laufen zu halten
dann sieht man auch das versagen eines
systems das in seiner
rücksichtslosigkeit irgendwann an seine
grenzen gestoßen ist bevor es selbst
unterging
[Musik]
in einem anderen wald im nordosten der
usa treffen wir auf unerwartete
fremdkörper ganz anderer art
[Musik]
wir sind in maine mitten in wunderschöne
natur
und plötzlich tauchen wie aus dem nichts
alte drahtseile und maschinen auf
[Musik]
da sind zwei identische
stahlkonstruktionen total verrostet und
hinten kommt so ein rohr aus
man erkennt einen alten motor hier muss
früher irgendeine art von
industrieanlagen gewesen sein
es sieht so aus als habe ein verrückter
wissenschaftler mitten in der wildnis
etwas fantastisches erschaffen wollen
aber was soll das gewesen seien und
welche rolle haben diese ausrangierten
lokomotiven gespielt
[Musik]
dann stoßen wir auf ein altes seilzug
system und verrostete metallteile die
reste von bahngleisen aussehen
der ganze wald gibt rätsel auf
normalerweise verbinden sie ihnen
verschiedene punkte miteinander
diese hören einfach irgendwo auf oder
findet sich doch irgendwo eine
verbindung zwischen den einzelteilen
denn man darf auch nicht vergessen dass
der ort extrem abgelegen ist tief im
hinterland von maine die frage lautet
was ist das und warum ist es hier
[Musik]
während des 19 und frühen 20
jahrhunderts spielt eine branche eine
wichtige rolle in den usa die
holzindustrie
[Musik]
wayne hat eine waldfläche von über
70.000 quadratkilometern
zur jahrhundertwende war es die
drehscheibe der holzindustrie und holz
war damals ein verkaufsschlager
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
erleben die usa eine phase mit rasantem
wachstum und großer nachfrage nach holz
[Musik]
in europa ist die industrielle
revolution ebenfalls im vollen gange
auch dort herrscht großer bedarf
vermutlich hat man ihn vorübergehend
sogar den weltgrößten holzhandel hafen
[Musik]
in windeseile werden riesige waldflächen
abgeholzt sägemühlen machen das große
geschäft
[Musik]
matthews leiter eines naturparks in
maine kennt sich in den wäldern aus
die holzfäller kamen den flusslauf
fällten die kiefern und sofort alles weg
war nahmen sie sich das nächste stück
vor
die bäume fällen ist leicht schwierig
ist dagegen der abtransport zum sägewerk
oder zur papiermühle
die leester sägemühle war 200 kilometer
entfernt in bangkok sie mussten einen
weg finden das holz über einen schmalen
landstrich zu bringen der sich zwischen
zwei seen befand
der landstrich liegt zwischen dem igel
und dem change
[Musik]
das ist nur rund ein kilometer hätten
ochsen das holz gezogen hätte es sich
wahrscheinlich wie 100 kilometer
angefühlt
ein logistisches problem wie überbrückt
man das stück zwischen den seen auf
einfache und kostengünstige weise
[Musik]
die antwort ein
ausgeklügeltes system auf schienen
kabeln und eisen angetrieben von
modernster technik
das ganze nennt sich gelegt
im grunde war es eine kleine eisenbahn
die von einer kabel schlaufe gezogen und
mit dampf betrieben wurde ein power
racing
[Musik]
ein weiteres problem wie bringt man die
schweren gerätschaften zu einem
waldstück am ende der welt
sämtliches material wurde per bahn nach
greenville gebracht und
transportiert von da ging es mitten im
winter noch 60 km mit pferden und
schlitten weiter
der bau der anlage dauert ein ganzes
jahr und niemand weiß ob der plan
wirklich funktioniert
[Musik]
beim ersten versuch stellte sich heraus
dass die schrauben sich nicht fest genug
anziehen ließen
alles kam ins rutschen und nichts
funktionierte
sie mussten dann tausende schrauben
wieder raus drehen die gewinde
verlängern und alles wieder neu
zusammensetzen
als sie endlich fertig waren stellten
die arbeiter fest dass die wagen viel
langsamer waren als erwartet
dann merkten sie dass es auf der strecke
eine unebenheit gab erst wenn die wagen
diese überwunden hatten nahm der zug
richtig fahrt auf
der zug rollt aber ist er auch stark
genug für den transport tausende
holzstämme
die geleckt railway fuhr auf zwei ebenen
das holz wurde mit wagen wie dem da
drüben transportiert
es lag auf den spitzen vorsprüngen auf
das holz wurde aus dem igel league
gezogen über gefahren und dann in den
champions league geworfen von da ging es
weiter nach bangkok
die bahn schafft fünf kilometer pro
stunde sie wird mit dampf betrieben
in diesen kesseln wurde der dampf
erzeugt er wanderte durch die rohre der
oben bis zu diesem motor der dieses band
antrieb
damit wurde das getriebe in gang gesetzt
die räder da hinten mit den u förmigen
aussparungen waren mit den drahtseilen
verbunden
sie setzten die wagen in bewegung
für die damalige zeit eine tolle
konstruktions leistung
die geleckt runway ist von 1902 bis 1907
im einsatz und transportiert pro tag
durchschnittlich
1200 kubikmeter holz warum wird sie nach
so kurzer zeit schon wieder stillgelegt
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit hatten sie eine
kleine bahnlinie gebaut die den
abtransport des holzes erleichterte
im neu england gab es damals dutzende
solcher bahnstrecken sie schlugen eine
schneise in die wildnis und hatten
keinen anderen zweck als holz zu
transportieren
nachdem die tram way ihre arbeit
eingestellt hatte wurde einfach alles
stehen gelassen die demontage wäre zu
aufwendig gewesen vielleicht wollten die
betreiber sie auch irgendwann wieder
nutzen das passierte aber nicht
[Musik]
heute kostet die tramway nur noch vor
sich hin
[Musik]
manchmal treffe ich touristen die viele
fragen stellen wie kam das hierher wozu
war es da war es im betrieb dann wird
mir immer ganz warm ums herz
die tramway ist ein beispiel dafür wie
viel schweiß und kreativität in solche
projekte geflossen sind und damit auch
in den aufbau der usa
[Musik]
ingenieurs- und bauprojekte dem verfall
preisgegeben sie erzählen von krieg und
terror aber auch von fortschritt und
erfindergeist von alldem wozu menschen
fähig sind
[Musik]